it's impossible to understand bin laden
without reference to his religious
beliefs
this was a guy when he was a teenager
was praying seven times a day
fasting twice a week on the other hand
he was also a mass murderer
what was his relationship to religion
given how religious bin laden saw
himself it's not a surprise there's a
lot of religious material on these
drives
how great is allah
he would often recite verses from the
quran in his letters
he would refer to sayings of the prophet
muhammad in his speeches
thinks he's religious he thinks he was
doing the right thing
but he was not a religious authority
[Music]
he was not a graduate of a seminary or
any kind of traditional religious
training
and so we have someone who's a
non-specialist
making unorthodox interpretations of the
faith
because he actually starts by
acknowledging
that islam prohibits the killing of
non-combatants in warfare
but then goes on to explain in his mind
why the political situation that we are
living in
allows him to violate that
rule
what he did was to use political
justifications
to violate a religious edict
this homemade video found on the hard
drives begins as many of these al-qaeda
videos do by quoting
a religious verse with chanting in
tandem
and then the message becomes clear
we hit the united states and we scared
them
then inevitably bin laden himself speaks
preaching to his followers
[Music]
and i think it's a really telling piece
of propaganda
how it weaves together religious
imagery to superimpose them on
the tactics and actions of alcada
this homemade propaganda was crude but
tragically it was also effective
he was using religion as a tool
[Music]
does it mean to control people
to make people do whatever you want them
to do
and then justify the mean like any any
psychopath
justify anything i mean at one point he
actually told his commanders
don't shy away from shedding blood
you know if you look at the crusade do
you think christianity is a crusade
no the same thing it's people using
religion
to obtain political goals
[Music]
i think it's tragic that we let
a criminal define the religion
of 1.8 billion people
we would never take the word of the kkk
to define christianity
it would be ludicrous it would be
offensive
the quran is a recipe book and it called
for
a tablespoon of sugar in the recipe
an extremist would read that and put a
cup of sugar instead
so taking what the quran says and taking
it to its
extreme bin laden didn't do that he read
in the quran
you need a tablespoon of sugar and
instead he put
a cup of cyanide that's not an extremist
that's a deviant revisionist
bilan's view of his religion and
violence extended to his own family
terrorism was the family calling and he
was willing to sacrifice even those
closest to him
for his self-styled holy war
[Music]
you